foreign
directed it at the net and the uh eight foot seven
goal center for the Calgary Flames there made an
unbelievable stop now a chance thanks small Tucker
Robertson his first game is a crack in what a
story 240 gone one nothing Seattle how about this
pass by David Goyette luck part of your screen
beautiful pass just right in the real house
JT and you talk about putting it on a tee
what well I don't know about the 48. it's at the
end of the season JT now a chance for Dryden hunt
to the point shot taken goes wide hunt scores
with a yawning cage from a tough angle tried
and Hunt who's been a well-traveled veteran in
his time in the NHL he's tied the game I don't
think Ruby finds this Puck here after it's shot
from the point I don't think groovy finds it now
he doesn't he's just a step slow that puck ended
up being to his right and I don't know if JT he
thought it was in front of him or did he get
tangled up Bill Dunner was there in front I
don't know if he got tangled up with him as well
sail it out to neutralize McCann pepper down the
play gapping up Colton Pullman now solubioff
takes over this way for Dylan Dube Calgary did
not qualify for the postseason after a great
year two years ago so a goal for Elio salovio
as he Creeps in moves up from the deep and
all of a sudden kind of turns into a two
on one now what happens is Big stunt leaves
the middle of the ice that leaves the opening
and then the young d-man is able to
fire it over the uh stick side of
Philip grubauer and then able to create a
nice Cameron Hughes for Petro sepula out
to Center Shala hits the line leads it along
for Hughes for shaloff Leonard said no it's
loose he comes up big with Cameron
Hughes has room veneers just by him
dumel in a pinch and it comes out to Center as
we see turn it right back still McCracken counter
hamper Lee in front one hour big snow on Maddie
veneers transitions up Everly gets the sneak by
pass directed towards and that tips it in on the
dark forcing him to make a big save there's that
connection though able to find each other with the
one two quick going to the net yeah they're able
to take advantage of that long shift on the back
end Larson whites it along the Dasher far corner
there 82 in the blue crunched by Dylan Dube Belmar
centering pass a shot but our makes the same
working down low right here there you see
the interference there with Hughes [__]
isn't even there guy gets takes him out
and there you see Belmar from our supermo
just because because you could and they would
play it well they changed that over the years
outstanding save on Dylan Dube
but you have a whole preseason to kind of go
through that as a player and that should be your
mindset trying to make that next step and the
evaluation process too for the organization we
talked about the run for uh for Coachella Valley
last in the skates of Matthew Coronado who played
off the board good play it's done a lead pass
short-handed veneers McCann for the front McCann
rebound pitch Tie by done beautiful because
he knows that Coronado only has one Outlet
so he jumps the route gets it up in a
two on one and it goes right up the bar
downhill shoots it stopped by bladard back
it goes for Don I think that might have hit
Maddie in front of the net Johnny now done holding
onto it olowski in control advancing again here's
veneers [Applause] to the roof heavy veneers
on the power play and the Kraken have tied it
this is a fantastic play by Maddie veneers
in the middle polarowski finds him quick to
the backhand perfect view from my spot down here
not much room over the shoulder the dog is a big
goaltender and he puts it right in the corner
pocket yeah a little forehand backhand shovel
Ebbs is there as well he's got to worry about
blood will get that opportunity in whatever
role Dave Axel onto staff decides but uh talked
about the experience a little bit earlier and
never have enough of that especially on the back
end no and in this role this slot for dumeland a
moment we'll never forget now Adam Larson sends it
back for Vince Dunn on a change podorowski right
in he'll shift he'll shoot kicked out by Leonard
nice job there by polarowski changing that angle
this wasn't able to get a lot on It dumeland Wide
Open McCann he's in good Goods again Dan pledar
preseason for you too John usually I don't
know if you saw it but we were in a split
screen there and and Johnny's just started
walking towards the camera Stop Standing By
Myself waving like the queen well placed now
Hughes full big hunt to it you're gonna have
a good time aren't you Belmar kicked out ladar
going to go the distance tonight and why not
the way he's played well rested Johnny oh that
was a late hit there Don Larson blocked in front
Jonathan Asheboro out there for Calgary
can you mentioned how well Joey Deford
plays the puck let's keep an eye on that
here in overtime especially with all this
open Ice good point asparo back on it Breakout
tried and Hunt Calgary is changing hunt cuts
across goes wide shoots it off the glove up
to court Kevin Rooney Rooney with a shot for
the short side shut down by Decor out there
for about five minutes through Center done
the rebound plung line 149 left comes done
Everly handcuffed a bit of ladar one second left
it comes out to Center that's all [Applause]
penalty shots to determine the outcome the extra
point on the table Everly good stop by Dan vodar
who's been Rock Solid tonight not a lot of room
there JT when you get vodaros six seven we gotta
catch him in between he's getting ready to go down
see how he drops that blocker down there good save
jagor Sharon Govich that's a cross
on Joey decorde and he scores
comes in he makes his way back to the middle
the Court's right there for the shot for Seattle
we'll settle the puck down come in
slowly shut down by big Dan Vadar
[Applause]
see the positioning of the big goaltender wait
wait and Garrett tries to go five hole but
nothing there Dylan Dube still a young player but
a veteran in the National Hockey League [Music]
beautiful move and again the court got a piece of
it and that's all Calgary will win the
shootout win the game 3-2 [Applause]
Dube takes it from wide all the way
through he's going to work his way
back to the backhand double move the court
tries to get that leg at the last second
we'll get a good look here ready to bounce
in off of him right oh yeah I don't know if
it went off the right skate as well take
a look you go off the right skate as well
no just off the left one and barely finds the
back of the net beautiful move there by Dube
and good desperation from Decor he
does get a piece of it just not enough